but
[Music]
I'll be actually getting it up there
feeling pretty confident yeah at the
[ __ ] destroy Agassi space well if all
else fails my old friend the Soviet
Union job d-roc I mean even those shots
our goal we're not even close you did
only lose for three I'm impressed with
you we don't celebrate losing Kira and
no you're on a schedule
no worries so we're gonna try and get
you on there no don't over sweat it
rock'n'roll just in wow this is a pretty
exciting player must we play
excellent keep it away I want to win
totally different game it's got it's got
ping pong s things to it which I think
can help me we just seen highlights for
vlog we just made an animated gif of you
passing Brautigan baseline chance to be
on the same side is I'm really not you I
kind of wanted no you don't well why
don't you let Andre run pure well if I
can get people to buy into the strategy
but and then watch to me the perfect
storm is understand my religion and then
copy everything I do I start a podcast
you start a podcast I start doing more
filters you start doing why am i doing
less hashtags on Instagram not for like
[ __ ] hell like like get my mind set
and then do exactly what I'm doing yeah
I'm playing pickup you don't play
pickleball how are you Gary come on yes
thanks this is Ryan
you've never play this I played it once
once like but I to years ago how do you
ever play this no ever
yeah no it's exploding
magazine
Oh
mm and you just say that was proposed to
see never been there
[Applause]
[Music]
No
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
my god thank you my man appreciate it
good to see you okay guys stay well
thank you I think you and I as a team
can dominate these things at such a high
level thank you guys thank you excuse me
Baker your father loves my finger Oh
awesome
tell them I said hi small businesses in
the south get ready
we [ __ ] clock how many years ago two
and a half years in we [ __ ] unlocked
it get ready
offerings are coming let's [ __ ] go
the thirty second story is you go to the
grocery store to get a loaf of bread
it's been on the Shelf 1014 days host
is trying to make it 60 days you don't
know what it is
come to the store this is on the floor
you can have that hot loaf of bread
potatoes can I ask you a question say
yeah is this available yet did you rock
alright guys we got to run in the front
before we get South by if you're too
structured your father thank you
[Applause]
I can answer it while you're thinking
about it I think the worst advice slower
I think the worst I think the worst
advice I give is when I make it through
the eyes and ears and filter of who I am
as a person I think too way too many
people give advice predicated on
themselves a lot of the things I look
for our themes and but I spend a lot
more time looking at the collective than
myself because there's a lot of nuances
about me that doesn't map for other
people so I think way too many people's
advice is to singular and they and they
don't have empathy to understand the
subtleties of everybody else around them
[Applause]
ten years Rose has been a legacy clay
for me the thought of [ __ ] going bit
to do business there just because of
[ __ ] capital gains is not [ __ ]
smart period these may be a little more
extreme yeah yeah yeah I mean to me it's
just about value exchange
it's just reputation
named Stefan Stefan real pleasure speech
and thank you so much take care guys
say well nice to meet you my man hope if
we see in New York all right to cure
yourself Congrats on everything yeah
I'll see you may yeah hello how are you
great good to see you
let me tell you what's gonna happen
today we're going to have my company and
they're gonna give two-minute elevator
pitch and then they get six minutes of
is your mics on thank you how are you
all right here's the deal here the few
ground rules we have five amazing brave
entrepreneurs come up here for two
minutes
[Music]
my man you're important they're
important we need people to look at
we need bucket you saw what's-his-name
peel say the other day ivy nothing to
see the Oscars you know about this right
he's like he gave like Whoopi Goldberg a
shout I was like I was a little boy and
I watched you win an Academy Award and I
was like and I was like then I can be
like that's real like like like it's
real like there's so many kids that
struggle in school and like I need to be
out there really look I'm like you got
to see people and like you know it's
just important it's important if you're
a big heavyset black dude in [ __ ]
Alabama 16 right now and you're [ __ ]
smart it's nice to know it's true and
then my big thing is about like I'll be
honest with you
my big thing is if I do this for you and
I sit down and chop it up and break
bread with you then when Tyrone Thompson
from Ken Kansas hits you up I'm hoping
that it subconsciously not even like not
you being like all Gary did it just
subconsciously you're like yes people
wait to the
they wait till they win like I'm the
weights I win and then I'm gonna get
back what I like about you hearing is
that you documented this process all the
way while I was in love Brittany you can
follow in their process and you do what
you say you want a freaking dude there's
somebody people wouldn't talk they don't
friggin know nothin
my biggest thing is it's a and Phil will
tell you this Phil knows me very well
it's really funny I'm Phil indie rock
here they know me well for different
reasons my big thing is I often talk
about things I've done more than things
I'm gonna do and when I say I'm gonna do
things one of the things I do poorly is
I run my mouth like everybody else
it's just that then I [ __ ] take the L
like I tell you I don't think people
would understand how many bad deal
business things I do it's cuz I ran my
mouth and it matters more to deliver on
what I said then right yeah my great
vulnerability in the micro is that I
that I say yes too much
right [ __ ] wait a bit which is ship that
I've gotten better right or Joe smart
that was [ __ ] awesome you can email
me you can email me my [ __ ] but it's
in that yes that also makes me different
and special like there's people are
gonna beat me they'll make more money
I'm not built to make the most money but
[ __ ] there's no entrepreneur and
it's given back to the game like me and
I don't mean like here's a million
dollars for my name on the [ __ ]
school for Entrepreneurship that means
dick [ __ ] that means I feel good and I'm
cool like that that's [ __ ] ego I'm
giving back with a [ __ ] thing that
matters most my time my heart and my
[ __ ] head
[Music]